[Musik]
Ich begrüße Sie herzlich, Ihre Heiligkeit, wir
freuen uns über Ihr Nicht-Programm.
Sie haben das Kloster des Tibet-
Instituts seit den frühen 70er Jahren viele Male besucht,
was die Bedeutung dieses
Instituts für den tibetischen Buddhismus ist
Bieten Sie ein neues Zuhause, also eine
ziemlich große Vielfalt,
so dass der Buddhismus Teil der tibetischen Kultur ist.
Normalerweise unterscheide ich Religion und
kulturelles Erbe, Literatur, Religion,
jetzt eine riesige jüdisch-christliche Kultur, eine arabisch-
muslimische
Kultur  % der tibetischen Buddhisten, also
zögert unsere Kultur sehr,
Stiefel zu sein, deshalb lohnt es
sich, ein kleines buddhistisches Zentrum zu haben,
weil es sich lohnt, sich
jetzt hier niederzulassen, damit ihre kleine
Institution nützlich ist, also denke ich, dass das
Zentrum letztendlich ein Lernzentrum sein sollte
nicht nur eine Gebetshalle in diesem Teil,
sondern tatsächlich Wissen über den menschlichen Geist und
menschliche Emotes  In diesem Zusammenhang denke ich, dass Sie
sagen, akademisches Fach, nicht religiöses
Fach, da sie sagten, dass sich die religiöse Praxis seit der asiatisch-
indischen Tradition nicht in Gebet,
sondern in Training verwandelt, also ist dies ein Teil davon,
also denke ich, dass
das Studium, das ich in Indien mache, mehrere Jahrhunderte dauert  sehr
negativ, aber sie haben die Tradition ernsthaft
studiert mindestens zwanzig dreißig Jahre Studium zur
Verfügung an dieser Tradition, die in
tibetischer Tradition gehalten wird, also werden im Institut
spirituelle und wissenschaftliche Dinge
zusammengebracht
Aufnahme tibetischer Flüchtlinge, warum die
Schweiz, warum die Schweiz ein
Ort war, an den man vor anderen Ländern gehen konnte,
es ist nicht unsere Wahl,
aber sie ist das Angebot des Roten Kreuzes
Tibetisch ist auch ein hügeliges Land
und dann unterscheidet sich unser Land so
schön wie ein Tag sauber rein  Luft
wunderbar, aber eine sehr schlechte Einrichtung, lassen Sie sich
nicht übers Ohr hauen. Die Entwicklung dieses Landes
ist ein hügeliges Land, in dem die moderne
Technologie ebenfalls hoch entwickelt ist. Was
wussten Sie damals über die Schweizer Gesellschaft, wussten Sie, was damals
auf den
Kykladen geschah?  wir waren
in tibet erstens glaube ich eingeführt das
ist schweizer uhr erniedrigender knopf siehst du
hier oh das wurde in seinem kot gemacht
viele chinesen auch so seit meiner
kindheit natürlich deutsch und englisch natürlich
keine frage also dann siehst du auch die schweizer
gottvertraut in  unser Geist
also, nachdem wir offiziell
Flüchtling geworden sind und als wir das Angebot von
Jet-Assisted Cross erhalten haben, sind wir sehr
aufgeregt, aufgeregt und dankbar. Ja, lassen Sie uns
über die Gründung
des Tibet-Instituts sprechen
Ja,
was war ihr Interesse, beim
Aufbau eines solchen Instituts
zu
helfen? Ich
denke, eines  Sie erkennen auch, dass die tibetische einzigartige Antwort
an der Einhornsprache Univ nur eine einzigartige
Schrift zögert, so dass unsere Freunde immer mehr
erkennen, dass jeder Fall nicht
nur etwas bietet,
was die Einrichtung oder Einrichtung für
moderne Bildung ist, sondern nicht nur
die Bewahrung des
Tausendjährigen  Tradition dann sehen viele unsere Freunde
erkennen und wie und dann gibt es
auch das kulturelle Erbe ehrlich
wahrhaftig also unser verstorbener Freund Unterstützer
Herr Hara irgendwie härter einmal sagte er
mir sie möchte ich meine er ja er er möchte
dieser Person eine Firma mitteilen  siehe
Mitarbeiter in Polymer wir beschäftigen Tibeter
sind geprüfte Mitarbeiter Mitarbeiter das stimmt
und viele haben hier in der Schweiz Arbeit gefunden
das stimmt Ich glaube sie haben gedroht wir
sind derselbe Mensch das gleiche menschliche
Fleisch aber kleine Unterschiede wegen des
Naturschutzes lassen Sie uns über diese
erste Generation von Flüchtlingen sprechen  es gab
auch 160 tibetische Kinder,
die Anfang der 60er Jahre in die Schweiz gebracht oder geschickt wurden,
und sie  wurden in
Pflegefamilien hier in der Schweiz untergebracht. Ja,
es scheint, Sie hatten eine Vereinbarung mit diesen
Pflegefamilien, und der Plan war,
diesen Kindern die Schweizer Ausbildung zu geben, die
sie professionell ausbildete, und sie dann
zurück zu einer Debatte zu schicken. Können Sie uns etwas
über die Umstände sagen, die dazu geführt haben?  zu diesem
Plan
erstens in den frühen sechziger Jahren viele
Tibeter die Art und Weise, sein Straßenwasser zu verbrennen
Ich war dort, wo sie arbeiten, dort sind
Kinder, Bedingung, Vater, er ist gestorben,
also solch ein Ort
Familie, die
bis zu 30 Kinder adoptieren kann, also wenn er Samsara kontrolliert.
Ich denke, dass mich dann
damals meine ältere Schwester, die sich um seine
Kinder kümmert, den Zustand
in sehr armen Arbeitern in unserem eigenen schrieb. Ich sehe
den Weg, Kinder zu gründen  Dorf in
Bezug auf Allah über die Anzahl der Kinder
Tausende, also können wir uns nicht um all
diese verschiedenen Kinder kümmern, dann irgendein Schwesterfamilienangebot
,
wissen Sie nicht sehr zu schätzen, dann sehen Sie
s  Einige Kinder haben damals einige
Leute kritisiert, ein kleines Kind ist
es, eine Schwesterfamilie zu adoptieren, aber irgendwann
verlieren sie vielleicht die tibetische Sprache oder diese
Dinge, ja, aber dann ist es besser zu
leben, als in Straßenarbeitern zu sterben, er
kann das also nicht wissen
Das ist auch der Hauptgrund und dann diese
Tradition, die verschiedene Familien adoptierte, die
meisten von ihnen, denke ich, Riven-
Aktivitäten, dann werden sie schließlich
sehr nützlich, das war nicht dein
Plan, das war deine Absicht, aber ja, der
Plan ist gescheitert, das wissen wir heute
Kaum eines dieser Kinder kehrte
nach Tibet zurück, stattdessen hatten sie Probleme und
einige kehrten zurück, ja,
oh nach Indien, kehrten nach Tibet zurück, das ist
vorerst schwierig, es gibt keine Freiheit,
und tatsächlich waren einige chinesische Hardliner
sie wund oder besorgt
darüber, wie man Tibet behält  Als ein Teil Chinas
für immer, also wenn sie die separate
Identität getrennt von der Identität der
Tibeter sehen, eine andere Sprache, eine andere
Kultur, also haben sie wirklich
versucht, es zu minimieren  diese einzigartige Trennungsidentität
, deshalb
kehren sie vorerst nach Tibet zurück sehr schwierig sehr
schwierig
Lassen Sie uns ein wenig zu diesen
Kindern sagen, die heute in ihren 60ern sind
Wir wissen, dass viele von ihnen große
Kämpfe mit ihrer Identität
hatten, von denen viele getrennt wurden  Von ihren
Geschwistern und auch von ihren Eltern
können Sie sich auf die Qual der schmerzhaften Biografien beziehen, die
sie auf
diese Weise
durchgemacht haben, zunächst eine ziemlich stark besuchte Gemeinschaft
hier und das wie die Regan-Institution,
wo sie das bekommen und lernen können,
die Kultur zu lesen und untereinander zu diskutieren  Sie,
also sind diese nützlich, aber einige von ihnen
brachen mit der tibetischen Kultur, sie
wollten das kulturelle Erbe nicht übernehmen,
weil sie kämpfen mussten, weil sie in gewisser Weise Schweizer und
in gewisser Weise Tibeter waren, also
verstehen Sie die Bedürfnisse dieser
Menschen heute, ja  Einige haben sicherlich
körperliche Schwierigkeiten, wenn sie
Mira ein tibetisches Gesicht ansehen, ja, aber das Zuhause,
in dem sie leben,
ist europäisch, ja, und educati  auf eine
europäische Bildung, aber okay, es sollte sein,
dass wir Menschen retten. Glauben Sie, dass
sie eine Art Dialog mit Ihrer
Heiligkeit brauchen, um an ihrer Biografie
und ihrer Lebensgeschichte zu arbeiten? Okay, wir haben
hier Ihre Organisation und einschließlich
Ihrer eigenen Institution  Sie sehen, ich denke,
wir sollten irgendwann ein Programm haben, in
einer Woche oder zwei Wochen. Ich habe solche
Kinder versammelt und den vierten Elternteil eingeschlossen, der
abwesend ist, besprechen Sie, dass Sie sich auf Aufklärung beziehen,
aber Sie persönlich wären
bereit und bereit, sich für einen
persönlichen Dialog mit ihnen zu öffnen  das ist es nicht
Ich lasse Zweifel Delta morgen yeah
bruh yeah ich liebe die TJ's also wenn es
nur gibt bin ich sehr glücklich aber jetzt keine zeit okay
ich denke unsere andere institution dann
ideal morgen ich werde tibetisch sprechen in ordnung
sonny so  ich darf
auf dieses produkt hinweisen danke kein problem
okay trotzdem wenn schweizer etwas
fremd dann anders aber du bist der
selbe mensch der psychisch
seelisch körperlich
also so ist  Ich Leute haben geheiratet, was
sie nur eine Person ist, okay, nein, das Recon
Institute wurde 1986 gegründet und das
Jahr 1986 markiert große gesellschaftliche Revolutionen
in den westlichen Ländern, also wurden Autoritäten
herausgefordert, religiöse Führer, Eltern,
Lehrer wurden herausgefordert und die Jugend
revoltierte und gleichzeitig das Recon
Institute  bot ein Programm an,
das in die andere Richtung ging, wie sehr
traditionelle Lehren und sehr
traditionelle Lernmethoden. Wussten Sie
damals, dass diese beiden
Dinge in völlig andere Richtungen gehen
?  so eine Form und
andere Lebensweise und andere
Lehre, aber wenn Sie aus Ihrer Perspektive schauen, werden
wir alle einfach
kein Problem sein, und eigentlich ist es jetzt ein zu
Ende gegangenes Jahrhundert, im
Gegensatz zu Anfang des Jahrhunderts, hat
sich in Europa viel verändert, was die Europäische Union
früh entwickelt hat  Teil des Jahrhunderts
unmöglich, Europäische Union zu denken, also
sie alle diese Se  nse der Einheit und
eine größere Gemeinschaft in Betracht zu ziehen, also fühlte ich mich
sehr von Ihnen angezogen, sehen Sie, dass Sie der
Geist der Union sein werden, also der grundlegende Bereich, der
gleiche Mensch, geistig, emotional,
körperlich, wie ich zuvor erwähnt habe. Ja,
ich darf Ihnen noch eine letzte Frage stellen.
Manchmal setzen wir uns Ziele  in unserem Leben, das
wir nie erreichen, und manchmal
erreichen wir etwas, das wir nie angestrebt haben,
gibt es so etwas in Ihrem Leben,
oh ja, als Flüchtling, der unser eigenes Land verloren hat
, das viele neue Möglichkeiten gebracht hat, wenn
ich immer noch in Tibet bleibe, ich sicherlich
sehr feindselig geworden
zu viel offizielle Formalität als
Flüchtling sehr sehr glücklich
gebaut ich fühle mich als Flüchtling bin ich
wirklich nur echter Mensch geworden ein älterer
Hund traditionell das Lama aus
der Gemeinschaft isolieren das sie aber auch ich denke
als Flüchtling erste Chance  eine
bessere Gelegenheit, moderne
Bildung und modernes Wissen zu studieren Zahl der
Tibeter, die aus Tibet kommen, die
in Indien geboren sind, stehen jetzt ziemlich über ihrem
Beruf und mir  Vor einiger Zeit tragen wir auch
das tausendjährige Wissen unserer Tradition
hier in die Vergangenheit. Ich denke
, um ein Gelehrter zu werden,
studiere jetzt in Indien mindestens zwei Jahre,
um ein Gelehrter
zu werden  Einige
tausend Nonnen studieren ernsthaft und werden
gute Gelehrte, weil sie
Schüler werden, wofür, für wissenschaftliche
Fächer oder um dies zu bearbeiten. Ich beziehe mich auf unser
eigenes tausendjähriges Traditionswissen
über den Geist, über die Emotion,
jetzt erzähle ich es den Menschen, während
ich auf tiefere Erfahrungen gedient habe  Treffen mit
anderen Menschen Es ist eine Welt, die
durch eine Art emotionale Krise geht, also
hilft das Beten zu Gott nicht viel und was
ist das für ein Krebsmedikament Alkohol hilft nicht viel,
nur um den Geist zu trainieren, also müssen wir uns heute
verstecken, was wir bereits
jetzt brauchen  Das Verbergen von Emotionen sollte
beinhalten, ohne die Religion zu berühren, einfach
auf der Grundlage wissenschaftlicher Erkenntnisse, so
dass wir dort Buddhismus sagen,
einige Wissenschaften, einige Wissenschaftler sagen
Buddhi  sm ist keine Religion, die in
seiner Wissenschaft des Geistes ist, und jetzt ist es ein
chinesischer Gelehrter, sie beschreiben den tibetischen
Buddhismus, es ist ein sehr wissenschaftlicher, weil
Sie sehen, dass wir Buddha selbst klar gemacht haben,
oh, meine Anhänger, Mönche, Gelehrte sollten
meine Lehre nicht aus Glauben heraus annehmen
des Ozeans, sondern
untersuchen und experimentieren Sie lieber mit dieser sehr
wissenschaftlichen Herangehensweise, so dass einige
der An Allender des alten indischen
buddhistischen Meisters sogar einige
buddhistische Buddhas der alten Welt ablehnen, dachten, dass dieser
andere Zweck und andere Gruppen
, die zur Entwicklung der Methode beigetragen haben,
Disposition so wir  Ich kann all diese Dinge nicht akzeptieren.
Ich denke, keine Quantenphysik,
ein Inder, ein Kernphysiker, er
hat mir einmal gesagt, Quantenphysik im Westen,
etwas Neues, in Indien, vor über 2.600 Jahren,
entwickeln sich bereits Nadelbäume,
also sehen Sie dieses Wissen, sehr nützlich,
sehr nützlich, wirklich sehr, so gut
Vielen Dank, dass Sie hier sind
und sich die Zeit genommen haben, mit uns zu sprechen. Vielen Dank.
Ich sehe wirklich,
Sie wünschen sich einige  Art der Diskussion,
uralt, sie sagen, wie ich es denke,
Iran-Irak, dieser Bereich,
Astronomie, diese Dinge, die Sie sehen, entwickeln
diesen Bereich, also habe ich wirklich den Wunsch, einige
Diskussionen zu führen.
Musik]
du
[Musik]